we're about to show you how Captain
America faced off against Captain
America in Marvel Studios Avengers
endgame hey I'm the Stars and the
stripes I'm Lorraine you throw me I'll
come right back I'm like sick this is
Hearst mightiest show Hey later on
musician Ingrid Michaelson's gonna pop
in to talk about her family but first
here's our own agent M with the scoop on
cap versus cat oh that's really
America's ask I said ask hey Marvel fans
I'm Ryan pand I'll go say ka agent M and
I'm so excited to be sitting here with
VFX Supervisor of Marvel Studios
avengers endgame dandelo how you doing
Dan doing great so there's so much to
talk about in this film you work three
years on it I let's just dive right into
some stuff you ready yep
first thing I want to dig into Dan is
cap versus cap I don't believe you guys
have the technology to clone Chris Evans
yet not yet but how did we bring this
battle to life how do you have to
Captain America's fighting so intensely
a lot of the ways we shoot the fights is
that you'll have don't you'll get out
there and shoot it with two stunt
performers and then kind of run the
fight with them and then you'll bring
Chris Evans in and you'll shoot his side
of the fight but in this case he's shot
both sides and so same thing we shot
with two stunt stunt doubles and then
Chris would come in and play his side
and play the important side and so from
that you could kind of get the different
coverage you know both the studies and
the in the actors and then you get that
great you know great acting with them as
they fight you know originally we we
shot it without the cowl without the
helmet over the old suit but then when
we started testing the movie people were
losing track of which cap was which so
because we had the little bit cut on his
face and he would have gotten in the
Battle of New York but people weren't
following that so we ended up actually
having to put a cow a CG helmet on to
Avengers cap what we did is we worked
with Lola this visual effects company
and they have this thing we call the egg
you know any actor command and cryptic
Chris will come in and and you'll have
three cameras kind of from the general
angle and what you shot it and then from
that footage you'll take the three
cameras take the best angle build the
best angle
and then you know basically take Chris
Evans head plus face and put it on a
stunt double and the trick is that you
know a lot of times you you can't just
stretch the actors face to match the
stunt double head so you end up having
to like warp the stunt person's head
that's Chris Evans his head and then put
his face on it oh my gosh yeah so easy
sure so we're looking at this scene and
all of it essentially is created in VFX
which blew me away because when I
watched it I was like oh that's a really
cool set it looks so so much of it
seemed practical and seemed so real to
the point where there's like all this
glass and all this action that's going
on how much do you have to do to bridge
all those gaps and especially the glass
and those little particles seem wildly
intricate and difficult we knew when we
shot was gonna be glass all the artwork
that everyone was attracted to was kind
of this kind of big open space glass
skyscraper for portraying the insides of
a star tower and it's something that we
just we couldn't find practically and we
couldn't necessarily build so basically
everything you see we've basically
modeled I mean inside a star tower you
got one bridge that we built made of
glass that was reflecting green screen
so pretty much that was great to have
but then that got replaced got a lot too
because you couldn't fold the mat off
the green screen but all the offices you
see on the side or dressed you know I'd
like to see like you addresses sad you
just you know you built all the office
equipment you could possibly want and
start dressing everything from the sides
and it was interesting because with a
the set that we built digitally was was
incredibly detailed we found that we
were cutting it the there was so much
complexity to it that on the short cuts
of how we usually share fights you
couldn't follow the action anymore
because you needed to kind of get the
clean silhouette of CAP you know
fighting cap that that with all that
busy background so we ended up having to
go in and just adding a little more
atmosphere kind of cheating the depth of
field a little bit just to kind of pull
some of the detail out that we put into
it so your wasn't as much visual
information
to your ISO it was it was a roundabout
way to get there but you know end up
working in stark tower you know so much
of it is is VFX but there's also a
practical set of stairs that was
actually built how do you and the VFX
team you know work with the the
practical side of things to make sure
that all comes together it was like
shooting as much practically as we can
and it's we have this relationship with
with the stunt team and cap falling and
smacking things seems to be one of their
favorite things you kind of want you let
the stunt these do their craft and keep
them safe pan out whatever pants they
need and then you know but let them do
their wire work and you get that and you
know you kind of get just to that edge
of something that's it feels like it's
really gonna hurt but cap can survive it
and so when you look at the scene you've
got you know the bridge stunt T's fall
off the bridge then you cut wide you go
to see GDG doubles of cap and then the
shots looking down where they're bashing
between the two stairs and you're back
to stunt T's again yeah and then you're
painting out to the wires then so you
let them do it yeah and then that's what
Yanks it look real makes it make it look
feel like it hurts it definitely yeah
it's kind of a love letter to the fans
but it's kind of a love letter for us
too just because we had worked on so
many films and especially with caps so
that you know kind of you know when you
go into it it's like hey what has to
happen and it's like well you have to
have the shield throw you know you got
to get a shield throw and there's some
out you know it's a lot of the your love
of the characters I felt there was also
love for that American tuchus that we
saw there yes dan thanks so much for
sharing so much about Marvel Studios
Avengers endgame you guys make sure you
pick up the film now
[Music]
it is mind-blowing the work that goes
into this from all the fight choreo the
world
yes nuts you mentioned the fight card
learning two sides the same fights you
can fight yourself I mean it sounds like
a blast it sounds like my dream yourself
would you fight yourself oh absolutely
yeah same thing I would myself in a
minute RP yeah well listen you want to
fight yourself when you get Marvel
Studios Avengers end game on digital and
blu-ray now oh my gosh I can't wait
watch all the deleted scenes and
bloopers cuz that's my favorite hey wait
in the comics Captain America has fought
himself before hey that's true it was
actually a reality splintered evil
version of himself in the secret empire
comic book event yeah it was not nice he
was putting it mildly yeah he was quite
quite an evil person why everyone's a
fan of Captain America said the more the
merrier just not the bad ones yeah just
the good ones like like inin Marvel
Studios Avengers engage alright our next
guest Ingrid Michaelson is actually
taking her fandom to the next level with
her new album stranger songs check it
out I am here with the incredible
musician Ingrid Michaelson hello hi I'm
so excited to talk to you and especially
because I've heard that you you have
some Marvel fandom going on I do
my boyfriend's daughter and her
boyfriend are obsessed Marvel so I had a
spider-gwen cake made for her birthday
and I specifically you know designed it
myself based on her colors the pink
turquoise blue and white and had a
little spider-gwen cake topper so you've
all have been I didn't make the cake
I designed the cake and then you were a
cake I picked it up and bought it yes
yes architect but let's talk about your
new album stranger songs which is
incredible I've been listening to it
weirdly on repeat at my desk where did
the album come from I know you're a big
stranger things fan and clearly it's
also a near family yes so I love the
show I love nostalgia I love sci-fi and
I wanted to do something that was
different and inspiring and this show
specifically it was just one of those
things that I like allowed myself to
just get lost in the
way it makes me feel reminds me of my
youth so I started writing poems about
the show and then I was like if I'm
writing poems about the show maybe I
should write a song about this and then
it just started forming these songs from
the point of view of all the characters
but if you haven't seen the show you
still can appreciate it it's not like so
specific that you won't get what the
songs about but if you know the show
you're like oh I know that is oh I know
what that is like little Easter eggs
everywhere I especially love the song
pretty and I loved the sentiment that
you shared with it about what that song
was about would you talk a little yeah
so there's that scene where they dressed
eleven up in a blond wig and a pink
dress and Mike's like oh you look pretty
good you look pretty good cuz he's
embarrassing I think she looks pretty
but the idea of what makes a girl or a
woman pretty what makes a woman
beautiful it's this sort of like blonde
hair pink dress trope that I think the
Defra Brothers were playing up on which
then of course she throws off basically
casts aside and it was just a concept of
what makes a woman beautiful I thought
it would be a really interesting take on
that scene and how to make something
very anthemic and powerful for for
people to listen to I found it so
stirring because there is something I
think you even say fight like a girl
yeah in the lyrics the strongest
character in the whole yeah show we
don't see that often a small girl is the
strongest character I mean like from the
beginning like it's just really rad well
because you seem to have this affinity
for girls superheroes I thought what if
we did a girl superhero quiz what do you
think yeah yeah great I'm gonna give you
some questions you're gonna give me your
answers we're all gonna be better for it
all right you desperately need a snack
what do you grab a nuts of course be
dinosaur shaped nuggets see a slice of
pizza or D a plant-based superfood
smoothie a piece of pizza oh yes well
you're from New York so yes that an
island yeah you know a good piece of za
za it's your day off where do you go eh
out with my big group of friends nope
the I hideout tinkering with a project
see I take a ride and feel the wind in
my hair or D I take time to meditate too
tinkering around the project excellent
or B whatever it was B - it is time to
get dressed
what is your style a yoga pants are
comfy and fashionable B overalls and
glasses please see I love a jumpsuit and
aviators or D something befitting
royalty glasses and overalls because
literally that's what I wear this is the
time amazing
so be it is who is your best friend
hey I have tons of best friends be my
pet and I are basically the same person
see they're a mouthy dynamo and my
partner in crime fighting or D I'm more
of a lone wolf or Panther see see a
mouthy dynamo I like it if you were a
song you'd be a my own hummable theme
song be mathematically perfect see
anything you can bump on the radio or D
the songs of My Ancestors a your own
hummable theme song I love it
alright Ingrid it looks like you got
mostly B's which means that you are most
like loon Ella Lafayette that's so cute
not only are you the smartest person on
earth oh you're a kid at heart maybe in
real life luckily you probably have a
giant dinosaur also to carry you around
since you're not old enough to drive oh
yeah my eight I love it
so yah my so young well well done you're
well on your way to also being a
superhero and congratulations on all of
your amazing endeavors Ingrid thank you
so much for talking with us yeah of
course you guys be sure to listen to
strangers songs wherever you listen to
music and check out Ingrid Michaelson
calm for tour dates and more bye thank
you
hey Lou nella Lafayette great choice
Grand Prix so identified with I
appreciate solitude sometimes as well so
it works out perfectly yeah it's great
we actually shot that interview with
Ingrid
for the news that David Harbor who plays
detective hopper on stranger things will
be in Marvel Studios Black Widow and I'm
sure she would have been so pumped to
know so now you know in great and joy
yes actually the rain you got to talk to
mr. David Harbor and say okay at San
Diego Comic Con so I you know what just
for fun let's take a quick look at David
Harbor on the press tour for Marvel
Studios Black Widow at SBCC what does it
mean for you to join the Marvel Universe
you're you're no stranger to fandom once
again what you did there right but what
does it mean to you to be part of MCU I
mean look these guys are like these guys
are like the best at what they do so
it's like you know it's like delicious I
don't know it's wonderful like it's the
scripts are so good the characters are
so good the directors Kate Shortland is
so good the movies are also unique in
and of themselves Black Widow is in a
way a departure I mean it feels almost
like an espionage movie it's got these
all these elements to it so it's like
wonderful I mean I wish I could say
things that were interesting in these
interviews but all I can say is like
it's great but it is it's great for us
that is great because we know nothing
thank you awesome awesome to see David
harbors passion already coming out of
his pores
I can't wait it's so good I love when I
see someone excited to join the MCU so
we can't wait yeah I can't wait either
to see Marvel Studios Black Widow in May
of 2020 May first yes okay we're gonna
attempt to be patient deep breaths and
oh it's gonna be hard a lot of a lot of
a lot of meditation yep all right tell
us what your favorite fight scene is in
Marvel Studios Avengers endgame use that
hashtag
Earth's Mightiest show tell us in the
comments and we might just use your
comment in a future episode but until
then we'll see you next time
I'm Laureen and I'm Langston this is
Marvel your universe
thanks for watching yours my tía show if
you like this like this leave us a
comment and subscribe to the Marvel
channel or click the box over there to
watch our last episode lorraine if you
bought yourself which one do you think
would win me but which one
me me which one is that either way I win